president Trump unloading on Nancy
Pelosi Joe Biden and other Democrats
during a fiery showdown with the media
Trump telling the House Speaker to put
up or shut up about impeachment he's
ready to send Pelosi a letter daring her
to put Democrats on record by holding a
vote this is the greatest witch hunt in
the history of our country so the
Democrats unfortunately they have the
votes they could vote very easily even
though most of them many of them don't
believe they should do Pelosi and and
their real leaders AOC plus 3 that's
their real leaders I really believe that
if they're going to pay a tremendous
price at the polls Trump also turning up
the heat on the Biden's it comes as
Ukraine's top prosecutor says he's
reviewing cases that involve the energy
company hunter Biden worked for the
president calling out what he says is
serious corruption from sleeping Joe and
his son I was investigated by the Obama
administration what I saw Biden do with
his son he is pillaging these countries
and he's hurting us we want to
investigate anything having to do with
corruption I'm only interested in
corruption I don't care about politics I
don't care about Biden's politics I've
watched Biden over the years and Biden
is not the brightest person I never
thought he was going to win he got taken
off of the garbage heap by Obama well
Trump fights back against impeachment a
member of the squad is threatening to
throw Trump officials in prison this is
the first time we've ever had a
situation like this so they're trying to
figure out no joke
now we remember Dana she was the one at
the beginning who says we have to
impeach the mother effer now she wants
to lock him up yeah so on the lock of my
thing so that's not how any of this
works but you know I think she probably
knows that she it was interesting to see
some of the reactions of these town
halls when these members were back and
hearing from them get a little bit ahead
of themselves and I imagine that Nancy
Pelosi who is wanting to be the very
measured person very thoughtful person
she's the prayerful one that she has all
these Democrats out there saying things
like we want to
well whatever Maxine Waters said I can't
remember that one solitary confinement
the the trumps White House is trying to
convince the American people that the
Democrats are just doing everything
political and that's working in their
favor in a lot of ways especially when
you have the chairman of the
Intelligence Committee Adam Schiff
getting four Pinocchios from the
Washington Post for not being fully
forthcoming about the committee's
contacts with the whistleblower before
the complaint was filed do you think
though that the White House has some
resetting to do as well because the more
they talk about this the more they're
not able to stay on that one key message
which is the Democrats or the do-nothing
Democrats and that we are actually here
doing stuff on behalf of the American
people talking about the economy the
unemployment rate down again to 3.5%
the stock market is having a little bit
of resurgence I look today conforth at
the house really isn't a question for
the Democrats they have 235 votes the
Senate there's very little chance like
legs maybe zero miniscule chance that
the Republicans would ever join the
Democrats in this effort so now really
it's in the court of public opinion the
American people will get decide but if I
were the white outside reset a little
bit over the weekend that should be the
cornerstone of the strategy it's the
do-nothing Democrats and this is a
partisan inside job which on you
mentioned the Pinocchio's the president
also mentioned some Pinocchio's let's
listen in one can react well I heard
Adams ships got four Pinocchios that's
good he should have got them two and a
half years ago when I speak to foreign
leaders I speak in an appropriate way
if you notice they don't mention the
ball that I had with the president of
Ukraine they don't mention that because
it was so good the only time they
mentioned it was when Adam Schiff made
it up you talk about Pinocchio's that
you'd get 10 Pinocchio's
10 it's quite a few one do you think do
you regret that Adam Schiff was it
wasn't honest when he didn't tell
everybody even people on his committee
that he met with the whistleblower
before where he didn't meet with the
miss his team did know people who are on
his staff right right but he didn't and
I think that he got four Pinocchios
because he never cleared up he had every
opportunity to say hey what I meant to
say was they didn't meet with me or with
the panel but or the committee but they
met with committee staff and so I think
he was properly chastened I think he
made a mistake and I think he made a
mistake with the parity you know I mean
I I understand it was just you know
summarizing with the president to say
but it's right there in front of you so
he should have just read it
my feeling is though it's pretty funny
to hear the president say this is all
about corruption I'm just concerned
about corruption I'm not concerned about
politics wait a minute I know the only
time I see him screaming about
corruption with the Ukrainians the
Russians anybody else it's Joe Biden or
Hillary Clinton I've not heard anybody
else cited by President Trump with
regard to corruption so I think this is
- I think Afghanistan he's mentioned
corruption corruption in China he has
mentioned corrupt China with UN yes
Dagan how do you see this unfolding at
the end of the week well everybody
always likes to act like president Trump
is unhinged but that was brilliant
political messaging because now he's
trying to change the focus not just from
Ukraine but to China and the Biden's and
more and more Joe Biden from the
Democrats perspective looks expendable
he's disposable he is political picnic
cutlery if you will they can get rid of
them they hate Trump more than they like
Joe Biden clearly they're betting this
impeachment push completely on the
Ukraine or Ukraine you said it's gonna
mean a drip drip drip drop drop plop
about hunter Biden coming out of the
Ukraine and his I mean it's obvious
influence peddling whether dough
whatever vice president knew about it or
not and it smells like pay to play
that's going to be the messaging Biden
already had a reputation for being
undisciplined lousy at fundraising he's
still lousy at fundraising rusty and
unfocused and he represents everything
that the very left-wing party hates I
think that he's a goner and he's barely
leading in the national polls and not
only that dot-com has a great piece
right now and it's citing devastating
characterizations of his fundraising
Hall by other Democrats in the party
he's actually lost momentum from the
first and second quarter here he's being
out raised not only by Sanders and
Warren but by Buddha judges that's not
good no it's not Jesse no it's not I'm
just thinking you know how about how it
wasn't too long ago the Dems cared so
much about pursuing corruption remember
that the collusion Deleuze they cared
but not when Trump wants to pursue
corruption so I tell them to SPF you
know what that stands for Dana I think
so
silence the false ukulele oh yes there's
the theory I have a theory on why the
media is talking about how angry Donald
Trump is as if they have nothing to do
with it right I have a theory on why
Donald Trump is actually expressing
anger and it has nothing to do with a
fear of the candidates because I do
believe that he really does want Joe
Biden which is why it's not a pullet
it's not a political thing it's a
corruption thing because he wants to go
up against Joe Biden because Joe Biden
is shaky he's like an Ikea dresser that
you put together yourself yeah that you
put together my theory is politics makes
everyone political by their team sport
structure right you're either on one
side or the other and I think that's
what's upsetting Trump is that as a once
a private citizen there were no sides to
him to him at all there were just people
you paid right
he gave donations to Republicans he gave
donations to Democrats now he's found
himself in this two-sided prison right
and he's like watching people call him
political who created the political
environment well before he got there and
while
he's there so he's trying to think about
this a guy that's never been political
who's basically co-ceo for the country
whether you like it or not he's got full
employment he's got a great economy
he got prison reform he got drug reform
he's got trade resets whether you like
it or not and wars are being drawn down
a lot of this stuff doesn't land on one
side it's on every side you could be a
lefty in like prison reform you can be a
riot II in like whatever else he's doing
the the immigration stuff the wars and
libertarians must love this guy so he is
not a partisan person so when you see
somebody who's angry he's angry that
there is a side going against him in
which he's trying to please all sides
and he's realize that that achievements
and their achievements are no match for
a political party married to the media
you can't get he's getting all this crap
done but nobody cares I don't you know
what about him what you just said was
it's all about him there's no party it's
the party of Trump what so what if he's
doing well though I mean prosperous yeah
it was peace and prosperous before but
I'm just saying Isis but I'll tell you
I'll tell you what strikes me is that he
said today the Democrats have the votes
to impeach him right and to me this was
an important thing to say because he's
saying you know what so that's gonna
happen he doesn't think they can beat
him in the Senate he will be no
conviction right so he is looking down
the road right my sense of this is that
he wants to win where jesse was talking
about earlier which is the persuadable
'he's right he wants to win in the court
of public opinion which he should well
he might I don't know he mean that's why
he's going after shift that's why he's
naked but but you got you got to come
back to the idea hey you know what we
don't need any of this we all have that
memo transcript and and also you have so
you have a litany of achievements and
you realize this tug of war is anything
it's anything but I mean it's all
political right it's all political I
feel like I'm the tour guide at
Universal Studios that I have to that
I'm actually showing the viewers how
this show is done that this is all a
show none of this is none of this is
real it's all political doesn't matter
who's in charge it's it what happened to
Obama happen to clean
it happened to push it happened to
Reagan and it's happening to Trump and
it's not just about Trump he wants
what's best for the American people and
he's watching Democrats do nothing on
the new NAFTA deal do nothing on drug
prices and not help anybody
I have achieve a better life yeah well
right that's the do-nothing Democrats
that's right that is so wrong